I go down to this dress oh my god okay
I'm not supposed to ask this verse but I
can't help it you can't walk up to me
looking like this and me not ask head to
toe what is gone thank you so much you
know I saw this dress walk down the red
carpet in Paris at the Valentino Haute
couture show and I just my jaw dropped
and I looked over at my stylist she was
sitting sitting a few seats away and she
just smelled to me I was like yes they
just knew I mean it I mean for god sakes
maybe you are doing it well to wear the
flash okay so you've said before you
were kind of familiar with the superhero
genre but you were a little unsure about
it what made you say for this one okay
I'm in you know I I knew I was in Y I
knew I was interested when Zack Snyder
who did justice Lee called me and you
know pitched it to me at first he said
you know I heard comic book and I heard
you know I don't know if that sounds
like my kind of world it seems like the
the you know the most complex fluke
flushed out nuances of of women in that
role in that world are really the
representational of the imagination and
wisdom of a fourteen-year-old boy the
audience are made meant to appeal to
typically and then he said no no that's
not her she's a warrior queen and I
survey it so I get a sword and a crown
and I knew I would say I knew I was
interested and then I read in the comic
book my first comic book ever and then
we meet her and the villager the
townspeople say is that is that aqua
woman and she stops and turns her on and
she says I have my own name I'm not aqua
woman I have a name on era and she's
that that's my kind of woman
you know she's empowered she woman's up
she's her own superhero she she doesn't
even save her she is she's a badass
character
I almost stood up and cheered today when
I saw you respond to folks that were
being just ridiculous and unfair about
your fashion choices why did you feel
like I need to say something you cuz I
mean you guys can push a lot of stuff
away but why did you need to say
something I thought I thought it was a
yeah I don't care what people have to
say about my fashion choices I dress
from my own so however to say I had a
malfunction because you can see my body
I'm not ashamed of it I don't care how
it looks to you or the effect it has on
you how dare you tell me it's a
malfunction my nipples or any other part
of me are not a malfunction then you
have just become up
[Music]